dink dink dink dink dink dink dink I'm
stuck on dink dink dink dink dink
I need a reset reset me ding hmm this
episode of the podcast brought to you by
me and the best underwear money can buy
three times softer than cotton right now
give 15% off reverse pair free shipping
and 100% satisfaction guaranteed you go
to me undies comm /e annejulien they've
onesies socks underwear whatever your
body wants they got it in super soft
form also post mates the best delivery
app ever we use it all the time pretty
much every day
you want something delivered to you
anything wherever you are use post
minutes 24 hours a day 365 days a year
download post mates in the App Store use
code Jena Julian you get $100 of free
delivery credit for your first 7 days
check it out really awesome app thank
you thank you sponsor are you ready
don't do that yeah I'm ready okay you
got your money ready I got the checkbook
ready alright cuz I'm ready to pitch
because I'm pitching today you pitch an
overhand or underhand doesn't matter
gonna warm it up both side arm I'm
alternating batters you're alternating
arms
you're right batters you're RHP than an
L HP no I'm going underhand one better
sound boss stop hold it overhand the
next batter okay they're never gonna
catch on to my style that's terrifying
yeah if you were the catcher too and
pretty much everything on that side of
him terrified yeah we're good luck thank
you I've I've set the record in the MLB
for most hit by pitches in one game I
wonder who actually holds that right
this is probably a really great record I
bet they have a plaque on their wall
probably somebody that throws sidearm
will you look it up most hit by pitches
in one game no in like in their career
movie or any emerges in a game I'm down
most hit by pitch pitcher okay let's see
huger Jennings
okay 287 hit by pitches
oh that's the player getting hit oh he's
been here yeah Craig Biggio he was an
astro and he used to get hit all the
time so it's they're like real over the
plate
yeah well they yeah they're like Craig
Biggio had a Crouch told like tiny right
box stance so yeah but who's the pitcher
that hit what pitcher hit the most
batters Gus weighing 277 most hit
batsman of a career chick Frazier has
219 pink Holly 210 and Walter Johnson
205 the only other pitchers to hit 200
or more batters in their career is a
special group of pitches out there they
give they give an amazing amount of well
they give no [ __ ] actually you called
in the plate he's coming for you Gus
weighing my dude he said an MLB record
just from dosing people nominal we'll
never know who knows the records his so
deal with it did he throw sidearm I
don't know
sure I want to know was he a
right-handed left-handed what was his
deal he huh Kinney Phasis oh that's what
he looked like oh this is like what
years career spanned 14 years from 1887
to 1901 he was small for a pitcher by
today's standard 5 feet 10 inches that's
not small to [ __ ]
I mean I'm taller than that but between
120 145 pounds he weighed 145 pounds his
win-loss record what 264 and 232
how did he win how did he place pitched
winning games well how long was his
career 14 years let's see how many pitch
okay a pitcher will throw what maybe 40
50 games a season maybe four let's just
say 40 let's just say 50 will be
generous 50 times 14
714 140 700 700 this picture looks like
one of those old-timey photo booths
basically so maybe he just wasn't that
good although honestly if you're gonna
have a win-loss record of around 400
games like hitting 200 people really I
guess 70 yeah that's that's a normal
record for that many years that's a lot
of games though right not a great record
264 and 232 it's pretty close they set
records that's all in that it Gus if you
play for 14 years and you hit a batter
200 times I'd be like that's fine is he
still alive Julian
oh no he no dead a long time ago I don't
know but he was pitching in 1887 yeah so
be pretty incredible if he was still
alive that would he would have cracked
the code to the Fountain of Youth just
become a pro ballplayer just hit
everybody didn't you it forever mm-hmm
I'm offending him now or his family I
mess up I'm offended yes you're my dude
anyway I don't know how we got so off
track but welcome to the tank don't
don't
how did we end up back here all roads
lead to the tank from the creator of
inventions such as mouse plaid and
vitamin ketchup I'm back y'all give me
your money
or I'm gonna run away with it anyway
what's up these inventions better not be
just puns I limited the amount of puns
because I know you really don't like
them it makes you mad and in order to
get your wallet I need you to be happy
okay so I'm help myself out here and
limit the amount of puns today on on our
episode of dink dink dink dink dink wait
I need to transfer this this file to you
because I'm gonna need to be on my phone
so you have to play this don't oh boy
sad shy docks your password except all
right I'm sending you the chins gonna be
the DJ slash the investor I'm Randy so
there's two ones the shark tank music
and ones the pitch music music is last
so you want me to what is this the
screen recording okay you want me to
play your pitch music for you yeah we
couldn't find the exact pitch music but
this is close enough go ahead what's
your name what do you do my name is take
deep breath are you nervous very nervous
don't be nervous for different reasons
has nothing to do with this okay I have
a big court date later today okay we
won't ask do you have that friend the
one who's always coming over to your
house unn mooster eyes their skin is
flaky and dry it doesn't matter the time
of year they don't ever moisturize and
you just want them to be moisturized but
you can't do it for them because that's
against social norms you can't just like
put lotion on people especially if they
don't want it but you know they need it
a lot of times they claim oh it's gonna
get all over my hands if I have to pull
ocean on and they don't understand that
is a price you have to pay to be
moisturized they are dry they're very
flaky and dry introducing the lotion
blaster 3,000,000 it's a gun that sprays
a laser beam of lotion to your friends
body it has a range of a hundred yards
with pinpoint accuracy it hurts a little
but it's fine
deal with it because now you're
moisturized it's a gun shoots lotion so
the problem is now gone of be of having
that under eyes friend because I think
that is a real problem that a lot of
people deal with it's a very specific
situation but I kind of feel like it's
it's relatable
anyway when they're not looking you just
snipe them across the living room and it
stings them a little bit only 5 out of
our 10 research test subjects have been
bruised the other 5 they ran away so we
couldn't see what happened but all I
know is 10 out of 10 we're moisturize
after so say goodbye to the awkward
conversation of asking them if they
would like some lotion and then
always inevitably denying you the lotion
even though you know they need it and
just shoot them with it with lotion
Boston or 3 million who wants to invest
sharks um how much are you asking for
not like money can I have like a $400
for for like I'll reserve like three or
four guns for you I don't get a
percentage of the business you want I
don't know what you want do you are you
can have a percentage I mean it's just
$400 you're like rich right you want
there you go
just imagine the possibilities it'll be
the most moisturize household lock I
need to understand the deal what do you
okay four hundred fifty nine dollars and
you get one percent and then you can
have a couple guns for you and your
friends do I get any lotion for the guns
bring your own lotion all lotions work
in it we only tested by three but they
all look like a cream well if it makes
it if it makes that sound it works in it
aquaphor anything that makes that sound
okay so you want 450 know you want $459
yes I get 1% yeah do you want to know
what we're gonna use the four-inch $59
for build a bigger gun for next year um
okay so I mean it's like it's under $500
just here's my response is it I think
that one note um even though you only
have 1% of the business that you now
take 99% of responsibility I have one
I'm nine years in the business
on paper you do most of the work deal I
think your products might offend some
people and hurt some people but your
intention is really good okay and it's
only four hundred fifty nine dollars so
yeah we got a deal thank you shark
I'll be in contact or I won't okay but I
wanna send you a gun for sure can't wait
thank you all right up next so Mike
what's our next deal welcome shirts that
startled you
I know it startled me even though I said
it my name is Hugh cubed my name is Hugh
you pronounce the G it's like you but
like you pronounce the G H ugh but you
pronounce the G huge okay my name is
Hugh thank you please don't laugh at my
name my name is huge aren't blenders
loud yes yeah
especially in the morning when you're
trying to blend your breakfast shake so
loud what's the deal with that well
turns out our team of researchers had
determined there's actually no reason
that they should be loud there's no
reason for it to be allowed they looked
into it in the science way and it
shouldn't be loud but anyway since we
couldn't find a reason
since we couldn't find a reason for it
to you know that it needed to be loud
we've came up with one introducing the
blender alarm
it's the blender so [ __ ] loud that
will serve as your alarm is your kitchen
far from your bedroom it doesn't matter
it's so loud you can hear it ring
through the neighborhood and don't worry
no one will call the cops because it's
very scary and they'll hide it sounds
like a horror film
but it'll get you up in a jiffy and your
breakfast shake will be all done just
don't clean him with water it won't be
good for you don't do don't clean it
with water
that's up to you just not water okay or
soap what are you asking I would like 15
percent of your pot your
tire and you can add the company you can
have it I'm telling you this is gonna be
big okay okay I mean it's really really
bad sounding like think about this think
of a mixture of the loudest piece of
machinery you've ever heard overlaid
with like ten people screaming at the
top of their lungs so like a jackhammer
party yeah yeah but miserable and but
it'll wake you up really fast and when
you turn on the setting for making your
shake / setting the alarm it only lasts
for five minutes that's it so only five
minutes straight which is 300 seconds of
it like that tell us about you how did
you come up with this product when I was
very young I fell on my ear and I
stopped being able to hear things most
things and so I had to come up with
different ways in my life to cope with
not you know only one year but I needed
things to be really loud okay so I
actually hacked my first pair of ear
pods to be just blaring loud in one air
pocket that's amazing because the air
buds only chemo relatively recently so
when I was five yeah and I'm six six I'm
hungry
it was last year when I do that I'm like
oh look it's raining look it's raining I
stole your money just give me all like
all your money or 90% of it and then you
can have this whole company in all my
blenders they don't come with the
charger I don't know where they all went
do you invest
I like your story
I like you unfortunately I don't want it
to exist I think you got a bright future
ahead of you huge the fact that you're
only six me really read or write so I
think it's gonna be difficult to be your
business that's understandable
just take me home okay let's take you
okay yeah okay can you stop it one two
three chunky cheese is you're supposed a
choice and we can go to check Yujin
thank you Emily crying okay is this a
new person perfect all right I'll take
you home after this okay Hugo up no put
in the tank is a min with it with a
product here he comes
my name is club called Club your name is
club club okay welcome club have you
ever done VR yeah what did you think
because most people enjoy VR although it
is pretty limiting because it only plays
games I want to have an experience in VR
not just a game there's no like VR porn
I don't I there's only games on VR
there's nothing
okay introducing V are you sure about
that
it's a VR mask that only plays John Cena
wrestling that's it that's all you get
to see and you need it probably because
it's really fun to watch John Cena
wrestling VR okay okay
also don't tell him that I'm doing this
he doesn't know
that's not right but if we're quick if
we're quick we can get away with us know
what okay I'm willing to make a deal
with him to make a V are you sure about
that game okay this and my deal with you
is contingent on we get John Cena on
board because if we don't we can't just
steal his wrestling highlights do you
understand change the name a little bit
like instead of cen a it's C E and na no
John Cena no there's still his wrestling
highlights so you like the name very
sure about that love it and the concept
and I think that people would like to
watch John Cena and wrestling highlights
in VR it would be great it would be
great you could be in the ring with him
looking around
well he's if that footage exists well we
have this technology to retro actively
insert 360 cameras in the middle of the
ring of all of his previous fights in
the past in the past retroactively we
can go in the past and do it I don't
know how that works but we have a team
that's very very good at things so okay
I'm willing to make a deal with you what
are you asking for I just need someone
to believe okay
I will believe if we get John Cena on
board okay so you know I'm right yeah
for sure
okay so let's pitch this together to
John Cena for B are you sure about that
John Cena or John Cena Cena Cena so to
ends no elisar the real one yes okay all
right let's all write him a letter first
so he knows we're coming
and I can't have $100,000 for this
project yes for that you said you
money - can I have a hundred thousand
dollars what are you gonna do with it
I'm going to invest in advertising only
okay you're not going on any vacations
are you no no I'm gonna create scam
Facebook ads that make it seem like
you're winning vacations so if you click
on it it says win this vacation you
click and then it grabs their
information that's morally reprehensible
Julian what are you using the hundred
thousand dollars for that is ethically
okay product development was a great
deal I really like the idea of VR you
sure about that
the are you sure about that we're gonna
use his face as the branding and
everything okay great
is your kid a filthy mess Oh huge oh I
don't have a name I'm just I'm just the
person so don't it's about the product I
don't want to have to what's your name
my name is orange green orange it's not
just the color of marbles pillow no
that's my name is orange green orange
again orange grand that's how you
pronounce it good clean fun ah I said
the name of their product 250 vas [ __ ]
okay
is your kid a filthy [ __ ] mess always
rolling around the mud
oinking it the other kids in the trough
do they refuse a bath or shower because
they're too busy having fun well time to
[ __ ] trick them
introducing the new play structure with
shower heads and drains built into it
introducing good clean fun the kid will
slide down the slide but simultaneously
get sprayed with water and soap so by
the time they're done they don't even
need to bathe they can finally and you
can I finally have some [ __ ] wine in
peace oh my god just don't get the soap
in their eyes because it might be toxic
I'm not sure yet
Julian okay what are you asking for I'm
asking for three hundred million dollars
for 50% of the business we'd be partners
baby I I don't have three hundred
million dollars
three hundred million bits
it's okay you have twitch bits I've
twitch bits okay I'll take some bits
okay here's my thoughts okay I think the
idea of a play structure with soap and
water is super fun except we can't
market it that our kids are stinky okay
it's gonna be like a fun so P so place
they are the stinkiest things on earth
no it's like a water park but with soap
so it needs to not be a playground it
needs to be more of like a bounce house
okay great summery and dangerous so the
hard plastic then no but we have to
teach them a lesson if they okay so a
bounce house with foam soap being
sprayed out of the for kids for kids
yeah is it like a theme park it'll be a
theme park in your yard you buy it and
you put it in your yard can you rent it
what if I don't want to keep it renting
it as a good idea
it's will do rentals subscriptions as
well yeah it sounds super fun but I
don't I have three million twitch bits I
do not have three million dollars three
hundred million okay great deal yeah
yeah I'll see you clean fun good clean
fun you need to change your marketing no
more have a glass of [ __ ] wine and no
more rolling around in their chops there
aren't gonna the other kids there know
saying kids are owning they are though
trying to be you know that's what they
do have you ever seen a kid don't say Oh
ink in the the marketing material please
I see us as you've ever seen a kid I
just assume that's what they do huge
back there if you want your home after
this do you need to take him outside to
go potty
he's not a dog oh I know but he goes
potty sometimes outside makes I ok sorry
I had to go potty
ok fine ready for the next one
post mates Julian it is a delivery app
hold on I'm gonna pitch it to you this
is a delivery app you download on your
phone okay and if you're at home if
you're at work if you're your friend's
house and you want to get some food at
your favorite restaurant nearby but you
don't want to get in your car and go out
and get it or walk over there or
whatever you coin the app and you pick
from the menu on your phone like you're
actually in the restaurant and then you
press submit and then a post mate who is
your mate right goes and gets it for you
in a timely manner and brings it back
and says here you go
and your first seven days if you use
coach Energy lien you get a hundred
dollars of free delivery credits added
to your account so you get food
delivered 365 days a year 24 hours a day
pretty damn good wherever you are
you look on post mates and you can find
a list of restaurants near you that will
deliver food to your house via a post
mate what do you think of that idea
you're moving your hands a lot he wants
you to pet it you go what do you think
of that idea it's pretty great it's a
good idea I think it's gonna catch on
probably speaking of catching on your
underwear is definitely not soft enough
because you don't have me oh nice and if
you do have me undies Congrats because
you're wearing the greatest underwear I
wear it all the time general where is
their onesies quite a bit we are in love
with me and E's okay super super soft
three times softer than cotton micro
modal fabric if you want you can also
sign up for their membership that
includes site-wide savings free shipping
and new undies delivered to your door
each month so every month you wake up
well you wake up a bunch of times in a
month but one day of the month you wake
up and there's a beautiful package of
soft underwear with a new print right at
your doorstep it's wonderful they even
have buddy bands which we love for the
dogs there little doggie bandanas same
soft fabric really really cute and
comfortable for your dog so right now go
to me undies comm slash Jenna Julian
check it out they have an amazing
amazing selection of underwear onesies
bra let's
all sorts of different soft things for
your body and you get 15% off your first
purchase in free shipping when you use
that URL or click the link below thank
you sponsors thank you sponsors okay
ready
different music so you know on your
Apple watch when you're going about your
day and there's an alert that comes up
that says take a breath you know talking
about right I think so I don't yeah it's
it's it's called the bre bap it says
breathe yeah basically saying relax you
don't know how to breathe I'm gonna tell
you how to do it that's what that's how
I read it
I am very annoyed at that I'm yeah but I
get where they're coming from yeah
breathe first of all I hate it and also
how boring second of all how boring
breathe that's what you're interrupting
me for so I can do something that I've
been doing all day and didn't have to
think about it is literally a human
function that you can do subconsciously
all the time and yet they want you to
focus on it for what mindfulness [ __ ]
off introducing I breathe 2.0 instead of
telling you to breathe and complimenting
you for doing so I breathe 2.0 will
challenge you right then in there to
hold your breath for an extended amount
of time if you fall short though it will
insult you loudly so you better not suck
you're holding your breath also you
cannot turn it off and it automatically
links to your scores to your social
media I am asking I'm looking for 15
$15,000 if you let me hack your Twitter
account and promote it for like a day
that's it that's the deal also because
you're in proximity to me it's already
on all of your watches and you can't
turn it off
what's the point of this app it's it's
an activity and it's too perfect a skill
which is holding your breath very long
and so you think the best way to hold
your breath really long is to just do it
regularly yeah random random times when
you're not ready
it just pops up and goes hold you breath
for two minutes ago and then if you fall
short
you get ridiculed by your devices
minutes is a long time well that's more
of the advanced mode the beginner mode
is a minute 59 Joleon novices have been
a beginner fit minute 58 baby is a
minute 57 your baby can play to just
$15,000 and I'll hack your account I
like you what are you doing later
I'm gonna pass okay well here's the
thing no I already said no I listen I
appreciate it very much
I already hacked to your account yeah
15k off yeah so good luck getting your
comeback I'm gonna keep hacking away
thank you goodbye okay my name is perma
my name is perma
hello perma hello Jenna do you like when
your boyfriend cuffs you in the bedroom
hello we know you probably do and that's
why we've invented a new product called
cuff i cuff me daddy Julian no it's a
pair of handcuffs that you link to your
heart right so when your heart rates
elevated because you're in a sexy mood
hold on a month on the cuffs we'll using
the power of magnets float from your
closet to above your bed and present
themselves to you and your special
friend they hurt a little bit but you
can just deal with it they also need to
charge for 24 hours per use I'm looking
for two hundred two hundred are you in
two hundred what decide later no you
can't just put your hand out two hundred
two hundred days of you giving me $100
each day you can have a free pair of I
cuffed me daddies and you can have as
many as you want for your friends also
you'd have ten percent of your cut of
the company which is two percent I would
be the remaining ninety-eight point
ninety eight
ninety point 98% so here's where I think
your strong suits are okay
what would shame again perma Parma Parma
I think you're really creative at
structuring deals and saying what you
want yes I am and telling me what I get
very good yes and that other people
should take notes on how to do deals
because what you just did was masterful
thank you I am a master um your product
is tanky and fun mm-hmm
i futuristic don't understand your heart
rate gets elevated when you're in a sexy
mood I I still had the cuffs read that I
still don't understand what you're
asking from me I need you to give me
money every day for like a hundred days
and you can have some of the company for
an exchange 33.3% of the company is
yours so if you give me money for a
hundred days in a row okay well do each
day will discuss the amount you plan to
talk do can you demonstrate the product
for me so you're laying in bed and he
nudges you and you know you know what's
happening you know your are your heart
rate starts to go up a little bit
meanwhile in the closet where you keep
the I cuff me you have to keep them in
the closet well wherever they are okay I
just need to be in proximity so okay you
know in the room they read that heart
rate elevation and they float with
magnets from where they are to above
your bed and just kind of float there
right until you're ready to grab them
and do your thing okay so my question
was if it says this is your heart rate
it doesn't just float out of the closet
and cuff you well you there are settings
for when it automatically cuffs please
always home invasion
you're not gonna flow it out of your
closet and cuff you why would it do that
I was a little confused how the product
worked oh but why would a home invasion
trigger it because your heart
is elevated no it only elevates during
sexy time I think does it elevate other
times well then what if you're working
out today know that your hurry
okay so I'll get back to you on that
come on I got it okay so if you're if
your heart rate is elevated for non sexy
reasons what will happen is we're going
to install a device inside the cuffs
where you say no quiero it has to be you
know you're know what is it called when
you're speaking for yourself it has to
be that form okay no quiero so it turns
around back to that spot so you just
need to be ready to speak a little
Spanish in a home invasion or when
you're working on I mean that's that
seems like a pretty easy workaround and
I just came up with it in 30 seconds so
imagine what I could do with 100 days of
taking out of the closet and just like
cuff to you we could do that no okay I'm
willing to invest if you can get the
deal is contingent on you getting the
note no quiero work okay no quiero okay
and that every day that we talk for a
hundred days you first find me a coffee
and you don't ask for anything more than
two hundred dollars per day per day you
got a deal miss don't say anything until
we shake hands absolutely
deal no and I can have your beanie I
really like that beanie
thank you good deal do you want one for
a personal use sure I'll try it I'm a
little afraid that it's it's gonna go
off at the wrong just gonna keep it in
the gym okay then we'll just be knocking
on the door
and just sayin okay okay do you ever
struggle do you ever struggle when
you're baking , life excuse me I
struggled baking all the time we know I
know I do
oh I once tried to make a Minecraft lava
cake and it didn't come out just because
the baking times were wrong right
totally now that is no longer a problem
now that is a problem with the past with
baked buddy
what is baked buddy well baked buddy's
your little friend who loves being in
the oven to watch over your delicious
food so he can let you know when it's
ready you program the recipe into him
via USB I think and when it's time to
take the food out of the oven
he will scream at the top of his
fake-ass lungs unmistakeably for you to
know it's time to get the food out oh
the oven but don't take him out of the
oven that is his home assembly required
lots of it
I've been required you must have a
Bluetooth compatible oven and he also
might be a demon what do you think who
is this product for it's for those who
want to bake I just don't know how to
calculate types you know a lot of timers
these days did you know that Google
homes and Amazon echoes don't time
things right if you say set a timer you
say hey Google timer 30 seconds it's
gonna set it for like 29 or 24 seconds
sure so I think that people that can't
bake generally struggle with the exact
measurements of things and doing things
in a certain process with mixing dry
ingredients first and wet ingredients
and things like that and also baking for
specific amounts of time well we did a
survey an elementary school and all of
our responses said the times that you're
supposed to bake for was the most
confusing part right because those are
elementary school children are they not
people they are people thank you they
are people are they our demographic
I'm gonna be real with you I don't know
what that word means
I can't you surveyed them because I hey
I couldn't get anywhere else so useful I
surveyed them are you allowed to do that
I'm here now I'll talk about the product
um I think it's horrifying and I'm gonna
pass okay first of all enjoy your burnt
ass cakes from now on second of all
please get reconsider no I'm gonna send
you a big buddy I do not want a little
sick energy in my oven I also don't have
a Bluetooth compatible of it nobody does
yes so who is your market it's a skin
okay thank you
I'm all set I'm scamming goodbye so I'm
here to scam you oh I'm sorry big buddy
we'll get it next time
all right get ready this is a long pitch
okay okay my name is Adam hi Adam
introducing hashtag adblock it's like
adblock but only for sponsored social
posts that's it
that's it damn so you know how adblock
detects ads on your you know web browser
and makes it so you don't to watch them
this will go into your social media
accounts and on your feed when anyone
hashtags add that tweet will not show up
I'm ready to buy I didn't tell you how
much how much I don't care it's free I
just want to know it's like when people
do hey I partnered up with Kmart to do
this really fun take me give me your
money
knock it on Instagram yeah you said it
to your social accounts so like
Instagram Twitter snapchat what is that
I know right
yeah but all the apps that you use for
social you just wanted like yeah you
could choose on youtube if you were like
I don't want to watch any sponsored
content exactly to block it all and so
instead of just blocking traditional add
videos and pictures that pop up it's
it's blocking those creators who are
doing pad posts no more hashtag ads on
your feed
am i right ladies and men I'm ready to
buy teal I'm giving it to you think
there's a market for that it's for free
thank you
next one okay another one with cell
phones we like reading text messages
just like you do okay
introducing the NS a please let us read
your text messages Julianne all you have
to do is go to iMessage NS a gov and
enter all your info that we asked for in
the more in we are the NSA you legally
have to do it right now now right now
you have to do right now okay come I
gone you're gone okay will be thought
will be speaking no we won't
[Music]
hello my name is salesman
my name is salesman I am telling you
about a great new product today it is
called special oil it is a
petroleum-based mineral / just oil that
is a cure-all elixir for many kinds of
physiological problems what problems do
you have
well special oil I will fix it and if
you don't believe me too bad I already
lifted your wallet when I came in here
what do you say why are so many these
pictures just you stealing my money
it's literally snake oil Wow good stuff
no come on give me your money
get out snake oil no it's the cure-all
No
[Music]
do you remember the phonebook how it
would just appear on your doorstep each
year how nostalgic it was also really
fun to have everyone's personal
information at your fingertips oh my god
well we're releasing it again but in the
2020 form introducing the phone book
again this time instead of a large book
we'll send a transition to your phone
and line by line in texts we will send
you everyone's information that would be
in that phone book there is no search
function and you cannot get it to stop
and it's kind of free what what do you
mean kind of free no it's kind of free
it's kind of evasive well it's not it's
not wasting trees we're not cutting down
trees I mean you know it's all digital
there's no footprint so can't trace us
it's a text message yeah text message
service with everyone's information yeah
it's like line by line search function
so you can't find anyone not just scroll
up or down yeah so it's like she's like
an onslaught of text you know but you're
just loaded with information and all
they they always say information is
power
do you want power I think they say
knowledge is power
I think it's information no I think you
can definitely not I'm gonna research
okay I'll double-check that but I think
it's information is power okay do you
want to invest no do you want the
service for free no it sounds awful we
are number one in the App Store no
you're not yeah the App Store a PP it's
the new app with another store inside of
it that only internally our company is
using no the App Store well where are
you going
I think even they hated that idea they
all hated that one get your bed Kermit
I'm trying to pitch here I got one more
idea here sit with you I got one more
idea here
you ready it's my last idea don't don't
don't give me the big song you know I
need a leader
[Music]
hello sharks
sharks do you remember me I was on a
couple seasons ago when I pitched you
vitamin ketchup welcome back thank you
and thank you again oh you get back I
snuck in okay and thank you for
congratulating me on all my success
you're welcome I got all three of your
letters I didn't write you a letter
french fries are the best and as you
know I am the ketchup connoisseur mm-hmm
a ketchup sewer french fries are fun but
they're a mess to eat if you're using
your hands you get grease everywhere and
if you use your a fork you're an insane
person
aha according to you agreed right you
don't use a fork for your fries what if
they're like chili cheese fries I'm
talking regular fries the kind that you
would just want with ketchup or tomato
so what do want to put vinegar on it and
you know we're talking about ketchup
situations here because that is what I
specialize in
I'm your ketchup guy okay I'm not here
to talk about vinegar or salt or chili
or anything like that so introducing
ketchup gloves a glove that is made
entirely a freeze-dried ketchup that
releases little parts of itself onto the
bite of fry that you pick up with your
finger and you can enjoy little bits of
catch-up with eat each bite of fries so
basically it is packed in there
freeze-dried but when it touches the fry
it melts into edible form so every
little bite little pieces of the glove
are now being part of the food until by
the time you're done the glove is gone
and there's no mess okay here's the
thing I don't think that's a bad idea
except you're constantly only ever using
the freeze-dried part that's touching
these fingers you're not you're not ever
picking up a french fry with the bottom
of your palm yeah but
okay the thumb would be extra thick okay
okay so you could go finger finger one
finger to finger three finger four palm
one palm to Palm
you have to pick up the fry like this
yes it takes a little bit of finessing
or you have to just pick them up with
your hands and shove them into your
mouth yes but think about this there's
no grease because you're not touching it
your hand is just covered in ketchup
glove like that and then if you just
like ketchup just stick your whole
[ __ ] hand in your mouth like this
ready like I can't do I can't do it I
did the other day I heard your jaw just
crack are you okay I I would love me to
invest but I really need a ride to the
ER okay
yes I'm I need a ride I'm in a lot of
pain are you actually no scary I'm
trying to scare you into giving me money
no how much do you want well I think to
develop a prototype we need maybe
fifteen or sixteen million and you can
have 25% of the company for that and I
promise I'll use it all RRD and I don't
have a gambling addiction I don't know
why I thought you're gonna ask I just
felt like that question was coming I
don't have one okay I don't make that
face of me I feel like this product
would be better if it were like two
little thimbles almost like finger
covers like why would you need a whole
glove made out of ketchup when you could
just do it on your two fingers you're
onto something I like where you're
coming from and you just replace them as
the ketchup goes down I like that
does it taste good oh really really well
yes so how does it if it's fries tried
yeah how does it like liquify is that
well once it gets in your mouth the heat
and the salt of the fries warm it up
upon impact we came up with a specific
formula of science so the fries have to
be hot yes also again if you're eating
cold fries I do I don't want you to use
my product period comma but if you are
using my product just heat up the fries
okay I don't have 15 million dollars
how about 13 billion 10 million 5
million give me a million you can have
20% do you have any sales well yes I
have 4 I have a boat and that has 4
cells and that's me me yeah just give me
your hand over good deal thank you so
much I'll be sending something to you at
some point in time you might hear from
I'm gonna be sending something to you at
some yes and you definitely don't have a
gambling addiction I like I said earlier
I don't have a gambling addiction why
are you looking around like that I gotta
go okay - Vegas thank you so much for
listening to my pitch I really
appreciate your time and I'm excited to
be partners with you all right me too
goodbye okay goodbye I disappeared
are you also a magician I know baby
thanks for the cash well we made it made
out with a nice haul today I'll tell you
I love when you sell me products I made
a lot of money you did make a lot with
very little promise to deliver on
anything yet if yeah but you know
sometimes you have to I don't know just
it's take people's money but get a
little creative with it so but I do
think ketchup gloves could be a big hit
I think I could I could be the ketchup
guy fight perfected vitamin ketchup and
then I also had the vitamin pin or the
ketchup pinchers right you could eat
fries like this and every little bite
would have even if it had like ketchup
flavoring or something you know maybe a
little bit on each we're onto something
there mm-hmm
where as you squeeze it it squeezed out
ketchup on to the fry
like the little ketchup packets but
they're shaped in like finger gloves
there's a little hole at the top so it's
it's just like a like a two finger glove
and it there's a canister like on your
yeah like spider-man yeah and then when
you squeeze the fry it squeezes out or
we could just straight-up steal
spider-man's idea except it's ketchup
instead of a web and so when you put it
in your mouth you go like this and
squirt ketchup into your which is not
gonna arm anymore top of your knife yes
no like it's coming up like that this
actually would work well with another
invention I had earlier what's that
lotion gun yes it would be shooting so
just change out the tank ones lotion
ones ketchup that's your equipped for
any situationally not a good idea and no
mess how well I left so okay a deal has
been made well thank you
Julian for your thanks for having me
thanks for having me in the tank y'all
it's always one of my favorite things
I appreciate it you can catch me on you
can buy my audiobook how it's I don't
have the title yeah but it's about
selling things okay so thanks for having
me on the podcast yeah this is the time
see you next time always it a brilliant
always brilliant with me yeah
see in Vegas okay goodbye
okay bye
[Music]
[Music]